and again you're going to have to in  their eyes they see mom and the fetus  they see the fetus as a child yeah we  see the child as a child it's funny the  way she's talking to these pro-abortion  people i know it's going to be really  hard but you're going to have to force  yourself to view the baby inside his  mother's womb as a baby inside his  mother's womb i know it's so crazy right  to imagine a child as a child yes  you have to if you're going to begin to  try to argue with a pro-lifer and you  support abortion you're going to have to  accept  the most basic facts about what is going  on before you're going to have a  fruitful conversation that's